[Música]
tuve
bien
[Música]
y
[Aplausos]
[Música]
nuestros abuelos amazónicos dicen que la
esencia real de la palabra es el sonido
cabe preguntar entonces siempre qué es
lo que hablamos que lo que compartimos
cabe preguntar entonces si cada palabra
está impregnada con nuestra emoción de
esta razón y nuestra acción
también dicen los abuelos amazónicos que
la palabra antecede la creación
que la palabra es inmensamente creadora
y genera realidades de ahí lo delicado
del uso de nuestra palabra lo importante
de hacer un uso adecuado de ella
nuestros abuelos amazónicos también
comparten que cada palabra tiene que
tener color olor sabor
figura y que hace de pasada por el fuego
de ave el fuego más propuesto más
profuso su sombra debe representarse en
la acción
hoy
me acompañó de mi compañera de vida de
mi compañera de camino encontrados en
este camino de la vida
natalia que es una gestora cultural y
comunitaria
que es anfitriona de visitantes
extranjeros y que se especializa en el
tema de el francés
y hoy estoy aquí con mi compañero de
vida quien es narrador oral y también
acompaña procesos pedagógicos desde el
lenguaje
nos encontramos dos hilos de la vida que
se fueron trenzando en un momento muy
importante en que compartíamos desde una
tradición ancestral una propuesta de
nombre shuar y shuar y desde el lenguaje
de las tribus amazónicas consideradas
como siria nos del amazonas la nación
tuvo humor y masa representa la acción
de reconstruir lo que se ha destejido
suar y también es una idea una idea que
nace de la necesidad de la urgencia
poder comenzar a sanar y acompañar para
una sociedad más sana y consciente y
revitalizar palabras ancestrales
prácticas
fortalecen nuestra palabra y que aportan
a una sociedad que parece cada vez más
confundida parece cada vez más
desorientada y a veces hasta enferma
y para eso estamos aquí compartirles que
eso haría y como nosotros acompañamos
esta palabra desde hace más de ocho años
este objeto que ven acá se llama fluir
y huir es un tejido que se hace para
soportar la canoa del conocimiento el
conocimiento que se representa a través
de la memoria de las historias de
sanación del pueblo tuvo una masa el
conocimiento que llega a través de las
plantas de conocimiento y de saber cómo
hace un poco nos expresaban
el conocimiento que llega a través de la
interiorización de la diferencia del
otro y el respeto por esa diferencia
sexual y también poder hablar y poder
eliminar el discurso persuasivo porque
no existen verdades absolutas existen
verdades faciales poder construir un
diálogo inteligente si la jerarquización
de los roles poder reconocer al otro en
su diferencia sabiendo que cada quien
tiene un rol que cumplir en esta
sociedad y cada quien nos aporta desde
su experiencia y desde su quehacer
parece ser que sólo desde un diálogo
coherente directo fraterno caluroso
podemos lograr una mejor comunicación en
un mundo que cada vez pese a las
tecnologías está más incomunicado más
fragmentado más desesperado y es desde
allí desde interiorizar que el otro es
diferente en poder acompañarlo en su
trasegar entender desde nuestra visión
desde lo que nos han compartido los
abuelos que no basta con decirle al otro
qué hacer si no estamos en la capacidad
de hacerlo con él
y acompañándonos de todas esas personas
que también han decidido caminar con
nosotros y que
nos verán después compartiendo esta
palabra en este espacio les agradecemos
profundamente que caminen para que estas
tradiciones indígenas no se queden
solamente allí en una palabra ancestral
sino que sea reconocida revitalizada
sostenida y caminada y crear esa palabra
también de ser aterrizada desde el
cotidiano y en nuestro cotidiano como
pareja las personas o las mujeres que
tengan pareja y hayas tenido la
oportunidad de ver con el masculino
poder hacer saber que es muy difícil y
en mi caso mucho más difícil cuando
vives con un cuentero
en definitiva natalia ya no me come
cuento y no me come cuento porque la
única palabra que se vuelve real y que
se puede compartir es la palabra que en
la acción demuestra que tiene ese sabor
ese color
esa figura porque por más cuentos que yo
haya aprendido en la vida no he
aprendido el primer cuento que me lave
la loza
y el primer cuento que me doble la ropa
y me la cómoda pero desde allí desde
entender el valor profundo de ser
correspondiente en la acción con la
palabra es que he podido
de alguna manera soportar los descensos
y encontrarnos en los consensos para no
salir corriendo pero porque no es el
vídeo corriendo también porque digamos
tiene sus descensos también hay el
reconocimiento de que el otro es válido
de que tiene mucho que aportar desde su
palabra
comprendemos que el amor desde nuestras
tradiciones indígenas se complementan se
sostienen y se construyen
mauricio y ha sido muy bonito porque
ambos somos trabajadores de la palabra
yo en francés más el tercer español y
dice que mi español es muy malo a veces
que aprenda primero hablar español y
luego francés
pero entonces mauricio a veces me
acompaña cuando tengo grupos numerosos
de franceses y esa palabra que me
sostiene me acompaña también me
fortalece porque valida la vida en la
vida de iu a pesar de que a veces no le
entiendan
pero existe la fuerza de una tradición
que caminamos y sostenemos y que nos
hace conscientes de que cada palabra
debe ser sostenida desde la acción y
desde la sutileza apropiada de lo
femenino desde encontrar los detalles la
pertinencia del detalle de él siempre
sugerirme la palabra adecuada para no
herir al otro desde ahí también su
presencia ha sido fundamental para
fortalecer este oficio que cada día nos
permite a nosotros vivir
entonces
sentimos que esta rehabilitación esa
revitalización de esta palabra ancestral
nos invita también a
poder entender que no es obsoleta que es
más que nunca urgente que es más que
nunca
es importante que no sepamos comunicar y
que cada uno desde nuestro oficio y
desde el ejemplo para nuestros hijos
podamos transmitir también una herencia
a veces es poco reconocida
ahora mauricio les va a compartir un
poquito de su oficio lo que hago lo
compartimos en casa y en familia no
tenemos televisión
y eso
parecería que fuera un problema pero
tenemos una sola hija o sea que no
la explosión demográfica no depende de
la presencia o no del televisor
depende de la conversación directa y
franca y afectuosa y calurosa que se
debe dar en el centro de la casa
[Música]
punto
cuentan que hace mucho tiempo por un
camino iba un perro reconociendo las
cosas que se presentaban a su alrededor
levantaba la pata marcaba el territorio
avanzaba otro tanto levantaba la pata y
marcaba el territorio caminando el perro
se encontró con una casa que tenía la
puerta abierta y sintió una inmensa
curiosidad y ustedes saben que la
curiosidad
pero instruyó al perro
el perro se acercó a la puerta olfateo y
decidió entrar y cuando entró quedo
[Música]
se encontró con mil perros como él
y pensó
y estos que
y los mil perros le respondieron
y pensó de nuevo que al estos xavier
años
[Música]
y los mis perros los mil perros le
respondieron
y vuelvo y pienso pero qué tal tan
atrevidos verano
y los mil perros
el perro dio la vuelta salió y dijo qué
lugar tan desagradable jamás volveré por
ata
[Música]
después de que detrás de este perro
venía otro siguiendo el rastro y hacía
lo mismo levantaba la pata marcaba el
territorio levantaba la pata marcaba el
territorio y caminar no se encontró con
la misma casa que aún tenía la puerta
abierta y decidió acercarse olfateo y
entró y cuando entró
se encontró con mil perros como él
y pensó
hoy te bacano qué cantidad de perros
eso
y los mil perros
y pensó y dijo pero si son simpáticos
mira
y los mil perros
el peso del proceso lo bueno viene que
ávila ni peso pues con la colita no
y paradójicamente
de una vuelta salió y dijo vaya qué
lugar tan agradable
cada vez que puedan vendré por acá
yo no sé si los perros cfi leer pero al
menos estos dos no
porque si hubiesen sabido leer hubiesen
leído que en la puerta de la casa había
un letrero que decía
la casa de los mil espejos
cada rostro es un espejo
[Aplausos]
solo para cerrar y despedirnos y
agradecerles solo que de cortarles una
recomendación nuestras culturas trailers
con este pensamiento que nos aporta
también nos ponen a meditar en el
pensamiento crítico que debemos tener
hacia cada información que nos llega
desde diferentes canales
no importa de donde nos llegue este fue
el camino que nosotros decidimos caminar
pero también dice los viejos que cada
idea que cada palabra debe ser
decepcionada separada observada
discernir
porque duden de todo hasta de esto que
les hemos compartido muchas gracias
gracias
[Aplausos]